okay again felix
what are you attracted to most in the
world besides balloons oh my god oh if
besides balloons
oh dude that was like oh that was the
uh balloons balloons of balloons yeah
that that's like the whole checklist is
balloon balloon balloon balloon balloon
balloon
if you have to say something attractive
about a balloon what would you say
oh like how when i rub my hands across
it gives like a little squigger
you know and then and then whenever you
blow it full of air and you like
pull pull the lips apart and go yeah
that's hot
that's hot yeah we let go of the balloon
it goes
goes around the room he's like oh you're
free
well i guess you share a lot with this
man who is attracted to balloons
oh oh he's attracted balloons it's funny
how you never know who
who these people are going to be like i
could never point at this guy but like
that that's the one
that's the one right there all right
let's see what this guy's all about
i'm 62 years old and i'm addicted to
balloons
hell yeah damn those are some big
i respect the size of the balloons i
think he's got a balloon under his shirt
though like look at that look at that
that's stretched man i don't know it's
about to pop
you should have needles around this kind
of oh no what's going on over here
start sweating no get the needles out of
here please anything with that
there is something about them popping
though
oh you think that's the thing like
is that that that release oh something
sweet
yeah do you think that that is that yeah
like you poke your finger through it
hard enough and it pops but then it like
kind of like
wraps shrink wraps around your finger
that's it that's it yeah that's that
good stuff
hey oh he walks around with that they're
soft smooth
delicate they're not soft are they
well they're what are you asking me if a
balloon is soft
have you ever seen a balloon
intellectually i know that balloons are
not alive
but sometimes i wonder if it's my love
for them that brings them to life
what that's a lot to digest here
right okay again how many times has this
man watched toy story
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're not alive they know that they're
not alive but
in my head but maybe they could be maybe
when i leave and when i leave the house
i leave the room while the balloons are
like
whoa man all right let's party everybody
hey
that guy's [ __ ] weird right
he keeps touching me and doing weird
things
my first reaction was wow blooms that's
kind of strange
that was not my reaction nah what was
your first reaction
i get it i'm in it yeah
cool yeah finally this is someone else
thank god it's not just me
being addicted to balloons for over five
decades
attraction to the shapes and colors well
the shape i can understand
how long how long's five decades
a long time it's online
wouldn't you say the shape the shape the
shape of a balloon
oh yeah it's very man likes his curves
yeah you get the nice curve
yeah yeah the little what you tied looks
kind of like a little
little little booty you know i'm saying
elena's saying oh
it feels bad when it's an old man it's
like oh
i was like oh this old man ain't hurting
anybody whatever
still make a make fun of me we don't
know if he hurts the balloons we'll see
and can't sleep
unless he's surrounded by them oh my
gosh
i like the crystal clear did the train
oh i thought he had like specific
balloons but he meant like the types
okay oh yeah the colors well like
because they die after a while right
they fizzle out they're not alive
[Music]
what happened every year they could be
when you leave the room they couldn't
just be like
i
it's like a soap bubble you know you can
see through it i've got
long ones the round ones but my favorite
is the
spherical ones coming out shape some
colors
what the heck is going on over here
there's wire management here
jesus he's generating his whole house by
rubbing balloons together for
electricity this dude must be a streamer
or youtuber he's got a lot of stuff
hooked up to that computer holy crap
it looks like the street the balloon is
a stream too
like a guy that prefers blondes or
brunettes you know
no that's not how that works old man
it's just my type you know
something i like some people like you
know blondes brunettes i like you know
balloons that are clear you know it's
the same thing exactly the same nothing
different
there's a big difference he even has an
entire room dedicated to balloons
okay that's unsurprising magenta
purple magenta that's the most
rarest balloon the race
how did he get nothing to do i can't
believe it
he's a real collector necessary to point
that out yeah he's got balloons in every
color what the hell is this but now we
gotta talk about the specific colors
all right tell me all about the magenta
balloons i'm listening
blue red and clear eau claire
that's his favorite that's the best one
i have a white one i don't have many
white ones but i try to put the white
ones in there like there's a white one
over there
that's really cool yeah if i
had i like what you did there with the
white ones you put them over there
there's a giant white in front of it
my wife he has a white where is he
ballooned
orange and yellow
but it doesn't have a green oh okay keep
all the colors you know uh
of the rainbow in there for me it's the
bigger the better of course i can't get
you know an eight-foot balloon in this
room so i settled for the five
foot uh you know weather balloon
compensate obviously
do you think you like uh flying balloons
oh
oh the hot air balloons hot air balloons
oh my god this dude he would probably
freaking just have a heart attack can we
go
pop like a balloon if he sees one
you can say it's mortality i want to see
the wife is it real
is it fake who knows i sleep in my
balloon room every night
julius's obsession with balloons goes
beyond shapes and colors
there we go oh sexual love
what what when i see a beautiful starts
to flutter
and i get aroused i'll take it
no one asks no one you you do not need
to share that
certain things you can keep up here my
dude it's a sexual thing
no no i like that the one scene they
have too when he's like standing in
front of like the uh
i don't it's like the blondes or
whatever it makes like a serial killer
though
like it's really crazy yeah yeah the
clear balloons
yeah they're my favorite
that way you can take a lot of abuse you
think he uses condoms and blows them up
did you hear what he said no he's saying
that he blows up the balloons
but he doesn't blow him up too much so
they can take the abuse
of his uh all right i'm done
that's all right thanks for watching
guys this has been great
wow he's abusive like the guy i knew it
four balloons oh my god he slaps them
what does he do to them balloons are you
okay
we gotta get these guys save these
balloons we gotta save the balloons
oh gosh do you think he draws faces on
them
[Music]
oh god you think you think he like
he like makes like like balloon animals
he draws a little smiley face on them
he's like oh yeah
and then he like goes he goes he goes up
there makes
the dog out of the balloons like oh yeah
this is a pony
[Music]
all right the faces as soon as it's
sexual it's just like all right
now you're lost i'm holding one you know
hold on somebody at least
i'll kiss it and it's like being in
heaven i mean don't you like to
hug and kiss the woman that you love oh
you have a wife
right the comment said he has a wife
does he like to
love and kisses his wife
i think his balloon is a wife she's a
place your pets now
hey i kiss i kiss and hold my
uh my microphone would you like
it looks so sweet too like a sweet old
man
screws balloons he's over here making
his face heavy right now it's creeping
me out
screws balloons i like that can we get
the shot of him doing it though
there's lots of people out there he's a
looner
but there's two groups of the lunar
group you've got
the loner get around
and you got your non-poppers
[Music]
we did not need those shots i definitely
do not need to see that
the poppers and the knob pop what do you
say
flicking the knob oh my god it's like a
navel isn't it
this dude this dude is a loon okay lunar
i'm i'm a knob flopper it's a balloon
lunar coomer if you know what i mean
julius's addiction to balloons started
when he was hospitalized at just four
years old
my mother come to visit one time and she
gave me a
real nice oh it's connected it's
connected to the mother
we got hannibal electro over here yeah
when i was four years old my mom gave me
a balloon and i just uh
i've been oh i just found love ever
since
just like when you were young someone
gave you a doll yeah and i just
just i gotta flop its knob every chance
i get you know
so after she left he just cried myself
to sleep
since then the sound of a balloon
devastates julius
and he even rescues balloons he believes
to be in danger
i'll go to car dealerships and um do
what i call a balloon rescue
when they stand right early there's a
bunch of balloons in the back of
floating away it looks like
what i call a balloon wrestling rescue
that everybody right now look inside the
balloon
and as the sun uh bakes on them they get
really dull
uh misshapen i feel you know like i give
them a second chance at life
love for balloons with many people wait
he just talked about how he screwed he
he he is a sexual thing for him
in these balloons he goes out and saves
them
and takes
fly away fly to the sky and pop as you
will my wife thinks it's strange
what
yeah it's real it's real wait
oh yes i'm so happy
please come on the show and tell us all
about it uh
my wife thinks it's weird right she
she called me [ __ ] saying we're
flicking some balloons and uh but he
sleeps every night in the balloon room
and and it's in there oh my just
imagine if you will you're the wife
right you're
you made some pancakes you're like honey
would you like some
and before you get the words out there's
a pop and you open the door
and this man is in there tears streaming
down his face
in a balloon hanging limply over his
i tried to rescue her
i did what i could do you think the wife
dresses up in balloons
oh my god probably not if she wants to
stay safe this guy would just freaking
be ravenous at that point
you're abusing me you're gonna pop me i
got a balloon
i'm a knob flopper or whatever it was
i'm a loner oh my god
why are you flicking my navel
stop it
[Music]
no no
would you like to be in the filming for
this your husband's addiction
hell no
no maybe she's not even real though
maybe
to confront the issue and convince
julius to see a therapist
i've heard through the family a little
i wonder how many people recover about
your balloons
so what kind of questions you have what
do you get out of your balloons
emotionally
when i inflate them it seems like they
come to life for me
really yeah i heard that there was a
some physical attachment to these
balloons
oh he's going there there's sexual
overtones to it
really overtones overtones what does
that mean right
no
your family your nephew's like hey uncle
i heard you like screwing balloons he's
like nah you know
this is a little awkward you shouldn't
be asking me this yeah you kiss a woman
okay
balloon i mean with that mustache you
know you probably have your choice of
girls out there you know what i'm saying
you like blondes and brunettes all the
same thing you know
[Music]
since is it a smell or if it's
all of it balloons don't smell ah get
out of here do they smile
yeah yeah they smell yeah they have a
balloon smell yeah
this guy's asking a lot of questions
he's like what they smell like all right
tell me all
about it what they feel like you know
what does that mean you got some extra
tunes
what are you holding out on me do you
think he likes uh gloves you know you
can blow out gloves oh like the latex
gloves oh yeah maybe
he's like oh they're balloons in their
cell you know you gotta save the glo
oh don't tell them that oh no oh he's
coming for gloves
run gloves if you're watching run no
hospital's safe
the looks the looks and i don't want to
you like the looks don't you
tell me more you like the color and
shape of them don't you oh yeah yeah you
like the size don't you
oh we have big brother any further into
that okay
you ever think that maybe there's
something wrong
nope yeah now
well let me go ahead and tell you it is
weird
it's weird it's fun it's weird as hell
the fact that your wife doesn't want to
be part of this program should be a
testimonial of itself
now she loves me it's all good ain't
hurting nobody saving balloons just
cause it doesn't hurt nobody
doesn't mean it hurt yourself oh no i'm
fine ain't the blue never hurt me none
it's all good
your wife is in pain she wants your
attention and love you don't even sleep
with her
if she would just be a balloon then it'd
be different but she ain't no god dang
balloon
i just got she's married to her for the
kids all right she's still
crying over that time you try to pop her
with a needle
yeah i ain't a popper i'm a i'm a knob
flopper or whatever
what whatever you did this is in pain
you're hurting everyone around you
no saying true and you know what
balloons aren't even that attractive
what the hell did you just say to me get
off my property
oh were you going to shoot me and then
you have to shoot
rosalind the balloon as well you don't
you you
don't you take it right here [ __ ]
[Music]
well sometimes i'll rescue them like at
a you know car dealership
then i'll spend a little time you know
if they're still floating i'll let them
float until they fall
if they already then you know and then
what and then i'll
untie them and powder them and put them
in a bag
powder and you say powder talcum powder
he's select
salvia elating just listening to this
what does he powder him is because he's
so old so whenever he's like doing his
doing his deed he just kind of like
smoked just kind of comes out
got a powder do not
i don't need to know about the powder
spare me the details
from sticking together okay all right
okay
all right i see that makes sense so you
mean after you're done with your
balloons and these sticky
powder rooms they don't stick together
okay got you like like a playboy
magazine you know the pages stick
together
did they ever go bad or anything oh yeah
if i don't take care of them
so when you take care of them
and yeah the balloons they got me
slobbering over here and tell me more
when they go
do they ever go bad
are there naughty balloons perhaps
do they float down on you if you know
what i'm saying
i've got something that's over 40 years
old really yeah
wow is it does it cost a lot of money
doing this
no i don't think so there's people that
spend more money
buying guns have you ever thought about
going well he ain't wrong there buddy
[Music]
you want to hear a bang i don't need to
buy a gun to get a booger to bang
yeah i like the way he's like you know
well i
don't cost that much money people spend
more things on i don't know groceries
and they do
balloons or you know [ __ ] idiots
water or
guns or it's fine ain't hurting nobody
i want to see the wife so bad i'm so mad
oh no
no no no no no
she's gonna powder
i don't have a problem right right now
embrace your voice
okay i'm not saying i got a problem i
don't yeah
give it up these questions that i ask
they're just strictly out of love
and concern and i don't want you to
think that there's anything else in that
would you be willing to go and and talk
to somebody
[ __ ] no okay what i've seen at
psychologists before and about the only
thing he said to me is
well you're not hurting anybody so why
worry about it
i see nothing wrong with it with loving
blood i'm going to continue
glove balloons because that's what makes
me happy
yeah that's what they say ain't
nobody nobody but a wife
seems to be a little bothered by it by
the fact that we're like a present
yeah so you tell me all about that i'm
mr
balloon boy this is a really perverted
ending of the movie up
no don't ruin that precious spell
oh no all right that was balloon man if
you enjoyed this video check out more
we've done then check out ken
subscribe and have great balloon free
[Music]
day
even ones
[Music]
i got something for you
[Applause]
you